so you have decided to play Amara or are
at least interested in playing Amara
well don't worry we have Jordan our
Amara expert here in the GameSpot office
Jordan we're gonna break down how Amaro
works how our skill trees work and what
are some best tips for Amara players
when playing through Borderlands 3 let's
start with her skill trees what are each
of her trees about okay so
Amara's three skill trees are fists of
the elements brawl and mystical assault
all of them are essentially just
different variations of getting Amara to
the middle of the fight as quickly as
possible because she does a lot of
damage at real close range so for
example the fist of the element skill
tree is about stopping the largest
threat so that you can deal with all the
smaller threats very quickly and then
focus on the big guy last whereas brawl
is about just jumping immediately into
the fight and mystical assault is kind
of to try to scatter enemies sig knock
them back on their feet and then you can
try to pick them off as they're trying
to recover okay
so what was the tree you went with what
do you find most useful for you at least
so I think that brawl is probably
Amara's best skill tree although I was
playing by my self for most of my time
with Borderlands 3 and brawl is kind of
her kind of self-sustaining skill tree
it's the one where she has the guardian
angel skill that allows her to just self
revive every two minutes so that's like
the skill tree you want to go into if
you're playing by yourself and you're
like I just need some defensive
abilities to make sure that I can
actually survive on my own but I also
really enjoyed investing in a few points
into her fist of the elements skill tree
which I think is probably the one that
you actually want to start with
especially if this is your first
Borderlands game or if you're just kind
of just getting into first-person
shooters and you just need a little bit
of assistance where are those specific
abilities he found useful
I would say in Fist of the elements in
her like very first tier she has a skill
called steady hands which increases her
weapon handling and accuracy so it just
makes it easier to actually hit your
target and just being able to use her
faze grasp ability to locked
one person in place just helps getting
those shots off so Borderlands 3 is
pretty hectic
lots of people running around this is
like the skill tree to kind of help you
stop all of that and try to get an
easier shot off to try to do as much
damage as possible it's also the tree
that if you invest five points into it
unlocks her second tier which unlocks
her perk which allows her to change her
active skill from doing shock damage to
fire damage in scenario damage and since
you mostly encounter bandits in the
beginning of Borderlands 3 being able to
do a lot of fire damage quickly and
effectively is probably the most useful
so you think maybe like invest in that
early on yeah I get that perk and then
maybe switch over to like a different
tree yeah exactly you have a few other
like second tier skills in there that
you could probably invest in a tempest
increases her elemental damage and
illuminated fist increases her melee
damage and allows her melee skill to
just incorporate whatever her active
skill element is so if you switch it
over to fire then all of her melee
attacks do fire damage which is just
very helpful in the beginning of the
game and then the last tree it seems
like you didn't really care for that one
as much yeah so mystical assault the
special action skill associated to this
one is called phase cast and phase cast
is when she like shoots out a projection
of herself which looks really cool and
does a lot of elemental damage but most
of the skills in this tree are designed
to increase the effectiveness of Amara's
action skills either she can use it more
often or it's just stronger and these
are all very good things but Amara is
already a very powerful character her
action skills are stupidly powerful like
I was able to by like the end of the
game just one-shot attacks with her
melee attacks I almost didn't even
actually have to use the guns in my
arsenal so using her action skill just
kind of made her almost too overpowered
but I can see how if you're playing with
multiple people and the enemies are kind
of stacked and becoming stronger this
might be the skill tree to invest in
points in
about halfway through the campaign when
enemies are a lot stronger and you might
just need that little bit of boost in
power and effectiveness okay so what
about weapons what what are Amara's
choice weapon types maybe brands that
you found useful for her so Mara has a
few skills like I said before that
increased her melee damage she also has
a few that just make her stronger the
closer she is to a person so close range
weapons are her bread-and-butter
close-range pistols shotguns assault
rifles that don't have really long range
scopes these are the things you want to
invest in I started with sniper rifles
for a while because I liked sniper
rifles and Borderlands games but it was
definitely clear about five hours and
that Amara's just not a sniper character
so it's kind of euro the person who
likes to go long range you're probably
better off picking one of the other
three as opposed to Amara well thank you
very much Jordan that is some pretty
good advice for Amara players sounds
like very much about shotguns getting
enclosed doing as much damage as
possible nope and if you are interested
in seeing how any of the other
characters play we have more guides for
all for Borderlands vault hunters on the
way you can also check out our witch
vault hunter is right for you video
which gives you a brief overview of each
character thanks for watching
[Music]